was amazing to work with Aaron Paul he
is so sweet and loving and just a really
really open warm kind person and just as
an actor is totally willing to be giving
in every single moment and just wants to
give you everything you need and there's
never any sort of wall up he's always
just honest and present and and also
just a really lovely human being to be
around I love him
challenging is kind of a hard word
because to do a film like smashed it was
I would say the most challenging because
it challenged me in so many ways it
challenged me personally and creatively
and emotionally but I wouldn't say that
it was hard I think doing kind of bigger
budget action films and things like that
that I've done that have been you know
shot over the course of six months
sometimes were harder because I had to
really work to keep my stamina up and to
keep the passion going and to be focused
on the character over that long span of
time so for this it was challenging in
so many ways but it was still fun and
kind of effortless as well
Thank You Quentin is just so much fun
he's just kind of the definition of fun
and exuberant exuberance and and joy and
passion for what he does and so I think
that I just learned to really to make
every day count and to make it fun and
to really give to all the people around
you I mean he really is just such a
positive force he loves to just kind of
take people aside and tell them what's
great about them you know just sit down
with a person and say this is why you're
so talented this is why I love you this
is why you're on my movie and I think
just giving that possible positivity on
such a regular basis makes such a
difference sent and I hope to to bring a
little bit of that you know to the job
myself
we even really expect anything from
director what I like in a director is
trust I like to be able to trust the
director and I like to feel that he
trusts me or he or she I'm sorry
trust me and and and so that's that just
makes a really big difference when you
feel that someone can trust your
instincts and isn't going to be afraid
of you doing something different than
what they had in mind that's what it
makes a really nice relationship and it
feels more like a collaboration
I think having worked as a child actor
and just having worked for so long now I
think I never really have to worry about
the discipline of being an actor and the
technical things that come along with it
because I feel like I got that from
training at such a young age you know I
don't really have to make myself sit
down and learn my lines or you know
remember to hit my mark and just show up
on work to work on time and things like
that that all that stuff just sort of
comes naturally to me it's just a part
of who I am and I can really focus on
the creative aspect of it so I'm very
very grateful for that background and
also it kind of reminds me that it is
play because that's what it started out
for me as it wasn't work it was play and
I did it because it was fun I didn't do
it to make money and I try to still have
that that mindset about it that if it
stops being fun then I have to make a
change because there's something about
it that I'm not doing right so I try to
keep that in mind